And it's then, when you're lost or uneasy or carried out of yourself,
that you find out who you are.
I don't believe that ignorance is bliss.
Science has unquestionably made our lives
brighter and longer and healthier.
And I am forever grateful to the teachers who showed me the laws of physics
and pointed out that three times three makes nine.
I can count that out on my fingers
any time of night or day.
But when a mathematician tells me
that minus three times minus three makes nine,
that's a kind of logic that almost feels like trust.
The opposite of knowledge, in other words, isn't always ignorance.
It can be wonder.
Or mystery.
Possibility.
And in my life, I've found it's the things I don't know
that have lifted me up and pushed me forwards
much more than the things I do know.
It's also the things I don't know
that have often brought me closer to everybody around me.
For eight straight Novembers, recently,
I traveled every year across Japan with the Dalai Lama.
And the one thing he said every day
that most seemed to give people reassurance and confidence
was, "I don't know."
"What's going to happen to Tibet?"
"When are we ever going to get world peace?"
"What's the best way to raise children?"
"Frankly," says this very wise man,
"I don't know."
The Nobel Prize-winning economist Daniel Kahneman
has spent more than 60 years now researching human behavior,
and his conclusion is
that we are always much more confident of what we think we know
than we should be.
We have, as he memorably puts it,
an "unlimited ability to ignore our ignorance."
We know -- quote, unquote -- our team is going to win this weekend,
and we only remember that knowledge
on the rare occasions when we're right.
Most of the time, we're in the dark.
And that's where real intimacy lies.
Do you know what your lover is going to do tomorrow?
Do you want to know?
The parents of us all, as some people call them,
Adam and Eve,
could never die, so long as they were eating from the tree of life.
But the minute they began nibbling
from the tree of the knowledge of good and evil,
they fell from their innocence.
They grew embarrassed and fretful,
self-conscious.
And they learned, a little too late, perhaps,
that there are certainly some things that we need to know,
but there are many, many more that are better left unexplored.
Now, when I was a kid,
I knew it all, of course.
I had been spending 20 years in classrooms collecting facts,
and I was actually in the information business,
writing articles for Time Magazine.
And I took my first real trip to Japan for two-and-a-half weeks,
and I came back with a 40-page essay
explaining every last detail about Japan's temples,
its fashions, its baseball games,
its soul.
But underneath all that,
something that I couldn't understand
so moved me for reasons I couldn't explain to you yet,
that I decided to go and live in Japan.
And now that I've been there for 28 years,
I really couldn't tell you very much at all
about my adopted home.
Which is wonderful,
because it means every day I'm making some new discovery,
and in the process,
looking around the corner and seeing the hundred thousand things
I'll never know.
Knowledge is a priceless gift.
But the illusion of knowledge can be more dangerous than ignorance.
Thinking that you know your lover
or your enemy
can be more treacherous
than acknowledging you'll never know them.
Every morning in Japan, as the sun is flooding into our little apartment,
I take great pains not to consult the weather forecast,
because if I do,
my mind will be overclouded, distracted,
even when the day is bright.
I've been a full-time writer now for 34 years.
And the one thing that I have learned
is that transformation comes when I'm not in charge,
when I don't know what's coming next,
when I can't assume I am bigger than everything around me.
And the same is true in love
or in moments of crisis.
Suddenly, we're back in that trishaw again
and we're bumping off the broad, well-lit streets;
and we're reminded, really, of the first law of travel
and, therefore, of life:
you're only as strong as your readiness to surrender.
In the end, perhaps,
being human
is much more important
than being fully in the know.
Thank you.
(Applause)